what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i have a special guest my little
brother
adam um he has never seen kevin samuels
before so today
he's going to be reacting to him for the
first
time how are you feeling adam uh ready
to
go back to sleep freaking tired
i tend to be excited tend to be excited
i'm i'm pretend full it protectfully
excited he's so excited to be here um
don't listen to anything he says
anyways um so this is kevin samuels this
is the video that made him go viral you
ready i don't know what this is so
i know but it's obviously not that viral
no he just did a million on youtube
still not that viral oh my god
i know who pewdiepie is that's pretty
viral
i'm gonna start the video can you hear
me now
those were hers hey can you hear me
yeah are you a phd i know i'm a phd
how many dollars you got i won
really i'm sorry what kind of dog is it
he's a cane corso he's a what
a cane corso what is that in english
um it's a larger dog and their breed is
meant for
guarding and protecting they're very
protective of their home and their
families
so what's your disagreement um honestly
i don't have a disagreement i just came
here because i honestly want some advice
from you
it says disagreement day i know but this
is my first time catching on live
normally i'm asleep
and um you have a job i do i own a
business
okay so i do too and i
do have a question all right first
minute what do you think
it's very long okay
but i have a business and if you wanted
my advice
you could always book a session if you
can't catch us at the show live
i'm definitely i was trying to go online
um earlier
but all you have to do man see what kind
of business do you own
i own a pet grooming doggy daycare and
okay so
what you're basically trying to do is i
have a disagreement day and you
basically came in and said damn your
topic
i want to ask you what i want to ask you
and that's
but you are more than welcome to go on
my website and purchase
your time to talk with me one-on-one
because what you're trying to do is
rather rude but i will go ahead and do
it because i'm going to use this as a
teaching lesson
how are you how old are you i'm 35
35 years old 35 years old and you're a
business owner
uh-huh uh-huh and what's your question
um so my issue is well
i want to know at what point when i'm
just meeting a guy do i tell him that
i'm a business owner because
um my problem is that when i try to
date down and i the conversation comes
up to where i own a business
um the guy is either like hey can i come
join in on you on that business
or can i put someone in and be a
business partner and
i'm not looking for that and i honestly
oh oh hold on hold on hold on hold on i
need to be clear on this subject
where are you where are you at north
carolina
and you're saying when to tell somebody
you own a business
because um i find when i date down
god to your interest and want to be like
a business partner
and i'm i'm learning that maybe i need a
high value mean because that's
well first off um do you know what a
high value man is
so the definition of a high value man in
the middle sphere is like i don't know
exactly i forget all the requirements
but
basically they have to make ten thousand
dollars a month for
three or more years so they have to make
100k for three or more years
um they can't have kids with like
multiple baby mamas none of that
um i forgot there's like a
the manosphere's gonna be so
disappointed i should know these but i
don't um
and i think like a certain height maybe
um and that just sounds like
what you should expect for everybody
no only ten percent of guys make six
figures holy [ __ ]
it's not very many man i really
understand uh
it's a small person what kind of man are
you talking about
because owning a business is no
different than having a job in my
opinion yeah
i'm not getting what you're saying when
should you i'm not understanding why
this is an
issue if you're if you're what kind of
men are you
what kind of men are you dating yeah um
i try to give i try to give guys
that not just you try to do what
i try to get guys that's not on my level
a chance
why what do you mean on your level what
does that mean
that's making six figures or more
but i don't under okay you try to give
guys who are
not on your level a chance why you know
because i want i honestly want a six
figure guy
um is what i'm realized okay so let me
just go ahead and edit it out for you
you ready uh-huh
the guys you want aren't asking you out
well i'm i haven't been putting myself
out there honestly
but you put yourself out there enough
for the guys you don't want
or believe you to ask you out those like
guys i met online
right so again
the men you want are not asking you out
see you ladies do this you go and
deal with men who you feel are beneath
you
and then you ask how to fix them i'm not
beneath you
i don't know how to fix a guy that
doesn't that's down there that's not my
concern
the better question is why can't you get
a guy on your level
that's the real question well the year
well first of all i would tell you what
i said
in here automatically is a problem why
you would come onto a show that you know
was a disagreement day
it's selfish it's like well
yes ma'am it's sell it's like i want
what i want
i don't i don't say things for no reason
that's why i asked you questions you're
35 years old a business owner
that means you understand what business
is and you know this is a business
and i have a and i have a show title and
you said
damn your show title i want to talk to
you
but you could have went to my business
and what do you think so far just
spot on i think he's very
he's slow getting to the point but i
also think he
it's a show yeah it's you gotta draw it
out at some point um
he spot on
but it is i mean i agree with everything
you said so far cause like the guys that
you want don't want
yeah because she doesn't put herself out
at the
point that they need that they expect
okay
book time to talk to me but you wanted
what you wanted how you want it
i'm sorry no it's but and i'm using this
as lesson that's the problem with too
many of you black women
you don't do [ __ ] the right way with
black men
that was improper and when i even when i
told you the right way you still were
like uh well whatever
so let me use this when was the last
time you had a
like the end relationship last year
around december how long did it last
a year a year uh and was that man
uh did you go to college
did i go to college yes
no sir okay how long have you owned your
own business
nine years and how and how long have you
been making six figures or more
on the last three okay why do you need a
man making six figures
um because i'm finding out that the guys
that i think that's not
is not working out what does that have
to do with money
because i feel like um
i need a god that i can respect and
admire
and i'm ambitious ambition and i want a
guy
that has that drive too and when he
doesn't i find myself
you know him like hey babe you can do
this and you can do that
and then all right so in north carolina
how what percentage of the population
what percentage of men in this country
make
six figures or more i think it's like
five percent i'm not closer to 10
so oh 10 all right so
the question is what do those men who
make that kind of money are you
surprised by that number
yeah i mean what did you think it was
i don't know i never really actually
thought about it i guess
um being america it's one of the bigger
nations in the world i just thought it
would be higher
um i i never really actually thought i
didn't do it though that much
i guess i never really realized a lot of
men just don't actually care that much
um well people are lazy in general
that's why i say they don't care that
much
who all women tend to want what do they
want
i feel like they won't arm candy
somebody who can
um have more to bring to the table than
just
looks but um also
bring balance to their life i feel like
i
can help them out on um okay slow down
i'm not understanding you said they want
arm candy then you contradicted yourself
yeah you they want somebody more than
just looks
you think they want arm candy
frequently oh i don't think men don't
actually care about the price
of a woman for the most part i think
they just want something that other men
will be jealous of
yeah well um that's why i've seen so
many girls that are like nasty
like get like pretty you know high value
men because they're just like pretty
but like you know guys are visual it is
what it is
yeah arm candy but something about you
know brain with it and
you know more in depth do you own do you
know any men who make six figures or
more
my dad and my uncle do you know
excuse me do you know any men that you
are related to to make six figures at
home
i'm related to yeah that you are not
related to
not on a personal level
so you don't know them you don't know
what they want
but you want him man
i'm going to suggest that you really
don't know
what you want
and saying six figures is just something
that you've
got taken from out there but i'm not
hearing this rooted to anything
but what do you want ultimately do you
want to be married children what
yes i want to be married do you want any
children
yes how many um
i have a son you know so
how's your son he's 13 where's the
father
he's not enough in his life
i say where's the father well he's
not like in it like i would like him to
be
all right so um go ahead and take this
down man
men who make the kind of money you're
talking about have options
and typically i don't want to deal with
women who are
have 13 year old sons who are used to
dating men who
this doesn't sound appealing
to the kind of man you're talking about
if a girl has a kid is it over with oh
yeah
if i make six figures and the man and
the woman
if she makes sick figures all right
there's more considered and then we go
into it more find out about the kid
all right is the kid a little [ __ ] or is
he like wait so you'd consider if
the so the money is important if she can
pay for the kid herself
if i don't have to do anything to do
deal with the kid okay
you don't have to if you married her
you'd have depends on where the kid is
okay
and as she said just kids with her so
that's where i'd be like all right maybe
i don't want it at all
well that's why like for me if a guy has
kids and their
mom has custody they're not going to be
around too much and that's my point of
view i
just don't want to be involved because
if the mom the biggest problem with our
nation today
is that it's not it's the lack of
fatherhood
it's not the it's not the it's not vice
versa it's not the mother raising it's
the lack of the father
and that's i
her making six figures and the kid not
having a dad i'm gonna bet money that
kid's a little [ __ ]
yeah okay do you understand what i'm
saying
insulting but just no i i i hear you i
hear you
statistics and facts yeah but um i was
thinking once i start booking session
with you
that um i can't change men i know but
i can approve myself and i feel like i
have a lot to offer to those type of me
okay but see you should have stopped
right there
i just told you i cannot change men and
you said once i book a session with you
i'm not a miracle worker i'm telling you
what they want
and you're still saying yeah but i want
them
they don't want you
but i have been working on myself this
year and um
50 years okay ma'am but okay
35 13 year old son
you might have been working on yourself
but like it doesn't just change over a
year
like and the fact that you have a kid
that doesn't go away and like
you if you're working on yourself you
got to work on everything like a kid
comes with it your life comes with it
there's
you can't work on one aspect and expect
all to succeed
well and she's clearly showing she
hasn't worked on herself that much by
calling out on the wrong day
and just not really listening yeah
with a sketchy father why would a man
sucks who's the top 10 of earners
who women across the country want
want that um
because i have a lot to offer um
i feel like you want your son
to if you had a son making that kind of
money
would you want him to bring home a woman
who had a 13 year old son
from a sketchy father or would you
prefer him to get a woman who had no
children was younger and easier to get
on his program
depending on his age this is this
see see what i mean see what i mean this
ghost
no i don't know he's on spot on point
yeah
even if a guy is 50 like i think he'd
prefer a woman
with no k i mean can he get that girl
probably most guys can't
but six figures he's going to get that
girl yeah that's actually
well the manosphere thinks that women
only date men for money
frequently yeah that's common they will
even
that should have been an easy question
no i would not want my son to bring
i want the best for my son that should
have been the appropriate answer
that's why i sat up that is
[ __ ]
you should want the best for your son of
course
but this is but and are you thinking
michael if he brought in
yes i feel like i'm gonna accept
no you're not that's the problem you all
think you're the exception to the rule
but but your life is proven to you that
you're not
my love life is not that good i agree
with you that's
my point and ma'am and that's my point
you ladies all feel like listen
you ladies all feel like you're the
exception to the rule
and then when someone like myself comes
along and gives you
a a dose of reality instead of just
accepting it it's like yeah but
yeah but i'm special you don't
know any men on this level
that are not your father that aren't
related to you that means you don't know
these
men you don't know where to go get them
you don't know what they want
but you're still saying pick me they
don't want
mid 30 year old baby mamas are trying to
be polite man but they don't want those
i asked you a question did you hear what
i said
yes why is that so okay go ahead
go ahead um
my from my point of view i feel like i i
get what you're saying they
they do have better options but also
those better options are younger girls
those younger girls don't necessarily
are necessarily
20 year olds are not necessarily
attracted to 45 year olds
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm 51. i can't beat
them off with a stick
that's another one on you lies no never
into the old guy thing but i've seen it
i've seen a lot of
i've seen enough of it to know it's real
it was just never me
when i lived in florida we met i met
dudes that were like in their 40s all
the time
and these girls were our age like i'm
going for them
yeah and these are like double their age
girl
no i know i've never been into that but
i mean i think once you hit like 25 it
stops being as big of a deal but under
the age of like
when i was like 21 22 i was not i
i just don't think i could date that
young i i couldn't imagine
when i was 16 a person not existing
like women always younger women are
attracted to older men what are you
talking about
so can you see me yes i can
okay so we knew a million people were
going to watch this clip
you feel like a woman like me uh-huh
what would you rank yourself on a scale
from one to ten you cannot use seven
what i rate myself just your face that's
clever
um my face is when i wake up five but
when i put myself together six
okay and how tall you agree
you maybe lower but
i give her a four or five yeah just like
but she's
thin so i think that might get her to a
six you know because she's
she's like then yeah i think my problem
is that majority of the world is then
um the majority of america is over the
world i know but like
we're talking about yeah the us but
that's because us is obese as hell
because we eat the wrong [ __ ] and
heart disease is the biggest killer okay
we're we're talking america that's who
she's competing with
yeah um honestly i think
for something what she wants she's gonna
go out of the nation because she's not
gonna succeed here
yeah dress size
i'm sorry your dress size
okay so that makes you if you give
yourself a five
that's average yes so
average looking women tend not to get
high earning men
they tend to get average men
so um did you did you i mean stop right
there
stop right there stop right there
breathe and digest
you're 35 years old and you can look
around and see the world
you don't tend to see higher earning men
with average looking women
off rip if you do see them
they got them they got their average
looking woman when they were both really
young and he built his way up
but a man earning the kind of money
you're talking about
does not go for an average looking woman
i mean my body is not average so but
ma'am you please don't make me say it
hey what
i really just wanted some advice i love
you i'm giving you i'm giving you advice
but you're not
taking it the advice is man
you're average looking at best
i'm taking it in but okay but you're not
accepting the fact
that okay
average looking women average looking
woman who's old you are watching closely
she does this the whole interview it's
so annoying
older average looking older woman with a
13 year old son
average looking woman with a 13 year old
son with a sketchy baby daddy
this gets worse every time i say
something
and now you're asking for a man who's in
the top 10 percent of men
you don't qualify for one
and you're making i mean i don't i don't
want to have to go there
but when you put in all these other
factors
why can't you just get a man that's an
average guy
sometimes i feel like um
in order to fully submit i have to feel
like he's in
well then you're gonna then you're gonna
die alone how about that
let me just cut to the chase man uh you
can feel like what you want to
but women like you die alone straight up
because you think you're better than the
men that you qualify for
and the only reason honestly ma'am that
i can see a woman like yourself
really thinking you deserve more is
because you earn more because you earn
more money than most people around you
in north carolina
but if your ass worked at the post
office you would not think so highly of
your
opportunities
and that's the reality we don't men
don't care about your money
not the kind of mean that you want we
don't care about your money
it ain't ours and we care about the fact
that you are older
and you got kids
and you're average
and your reality of your life has showed
you that
you don't have the kind of meaning that
you want knocking on your door trying to
find you
especially when you're on your phone the
entire interview
that she begged for see what we've done
in this country
this world is we've told women like
yourself
that you can have it all and you got a
prince charming
who's six foot a hundred six feet tall
six figure income jawline all this other
kind of stuff and i'm sorry man
no most people get average people
especially average people you're an
average person
i mean let's be real you're not running
microsoft you got you had a pet grooming
business
you've been making six figures for the
last three years
okay see how long that lasts
but if i'm looking at you but if i
looked at you and i took all that off of
you
all the eyelashes and all the hair what
do you look like under there
i mean i look the same i'm just no you
don't
because if you did you wouldn't have all
that on i'm sorry
no you don't you don't look the same
because if you did you wouldn't have all
that on
so what is your advice for
uh all right i'll tell you my advice man
because you're not listening to me this
is why i always recommend you need you
need
therapy everyone people think most of us
in black community need therapy but
you're not you're not dealing with
reality
i asked you about your child's father
and you couldn't answer me
but it doesn't sound like you're too
proud of him
how's what kind of student is your child
he's a a student does he have any
behavioral problems
no he actually got a youtube channel and
he's trying to i don't need that i don't
need no no
no but where is it but his daddy is
still
if his daddy is alive does he have a
relationship with his father
then what's your issue with him
um he's not um business-minded like my
father and my uncle and
then why'd you choose to make a baby
with him before you got married
young and dumb i was 16. exactly and
that cost
see that yummy dumb [ __ ] let me stop you
right here that young and dumb [ __ ] you
black women throw out
as if it's supposed to give listen and
listen well
women young and dumb is not a get out of
jail free card
it doesn't go woof and change the fact
you still have to carry that consequence
and men
are not rushing up to be stepfathers to
13 year olds
okay that's pretty much it what did you
think
um anything he said you disagree with no
i
he's pretty spot-on um
i like to but he's very slow
draws him out she also doesn't listening
but
he draws things out and that's not my
i have too much he has 80d
too much going through my head at all
times well he um
yeah he goes a little bit too slow for
me too but i usually watch at 2x speed i
just don't for the reactions
yeah that makes it better i don't care
for reactions usually
that's my thing is people getting
exposed is like
it's whatever you can do that to your
mom and she'd have the same
or similar reaction and yeah guess what
it's going to get you pissed
off mother like it gets you nothing
pissing people off and getting there
people called call into a show yeah you
know what i'm saying like like they at
like this is what he does he does dating
advice
yeah the mike's here adam
um okay well do you have any other
thoughts you want to put about the
show i mean i liked him he i i think he
puts off a very good
scene in how he tries to give off
everything and oh my god he has so much
more patience than i do right
that's what people think he's impatient
you think he's patient
more than i am that's for sure if i was
watching her video and i saw
her having her phone out while i'm
trying to while i'm answering her
questions
yeah and i'm responding her oh my god
no i just i was just just banned her
from every card no it was so annoying
the first time i watched that that was
what i noticed
too it's like dude like i like playing
with [ __ ] but i'm at least like focusing
on what you're saying
yeah this is this is mindless stupidity
she's probably focusing on the messages
more than she is listening right
well that's why she kept having him
repeat himself i know
okay well um guys you already know what
it is do not forget to subscribe to the
channel
bring that notification bell um i'm
trying to get to 20 000 subscribers so
each and every one of you helps me get
to that goal
um and i will talk to you guys next time
deuces